- Hi, everyone.
Welcome to our Homeroom livestream.
Sal here from Khan Academy.
I do have one announcement.
I think we've already made
this on social media and email,
but just to make sure
everyone's on the same page,
today was supposed to be
the day that we're going
to have Dr. Fauci on.
And I know myself and everyone here
is probably very excited about that.
Unfortunately, and fortunately,
he had to cancel for today,
but it got rescheduled till Friday.
So same time on Friday.
Hopefully, we're going to have Dr. Fauci.
So, continue to be very
excited about that.
And my apologies for those of you all
who have showed up today
and might be somewhat
disappointed only to see me.
So once again, Dr. Fauci
is going to be on Friday,
not today.
Today, we're going to
do an "Ask Me Anything".
So, start putting your questions in
on Facebook and YouTube
and I will get to them.
And before we do that, I will
do my standard announcement.
Remind folks that Khan
Academy is a not-for-profit,
that we can only exist with
philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself.
So definitely if you're
in a position to do so,
go to khanacademy.org/donate.
I want to give special thanks
to several organizations
that stepped up during the COVID crisis,
the school closures, when they realized
that we were already running
at a deficit pre-COVID,
and that our expenses have
only gone up since then.
Special thanks to Bank of America,
Google.org, AT&T, Fastly, Novartis,
and the Amgen Foundation.
Even with that significant support,
we continue to run into deficit.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about making a donation.
So with that, I'm eager to
answer all of your questions.
And I'll say it a couple of times,
because I think a lot of
people were going to tune in
for Dr. Fauci today.
He has, as I already mentioned,
he has been rescheduled till Friday.
So we look forward to that, but
I have a couple of questions
that have already been
backed up from the last AMA.
So I'll start with those and then,
but be sure to put
whatever questions you have
underneath the, whatever,
the message boards
on Facebook and YouTube.
So, there's a question here
from Anham Khan from YouTube.
"How did you come up with the idea
to make Khan Academy give
the gift of education
for an underfunded areas of the world?"
Well, Anham, I've talked
about this before,
I talk about it a lot, and you know,
Khan Academy, there's a long story
about how Khan Academy started.
It started as a project where
I was tutoring my family,
and one thing led to another,
and it soon became clear that
people who are not my cousins
were benefiting from it.
But very quickly, I started to realize
that we're in a moment, well,
even pre-Khan Academy, even
pre tutoring my cousins,
when you really, and this
is a thought experiment
I probably first went through
when I was in middle
school or high school.
I realized if you really peel the onion
on every issue in the world,
or whether it is economic inequality,
whether it is insecurity
around food or safety,
whether it's gender issues, race issues,
if you peel them slowly, but surely,
it really does often boil
down to an issue of education.
It boils down to an issue:
Do people have critical thinking skills?
Have they been able to
participate in the enlightenment,
(laughs) so to speak?
And that was always in
the back of my mind.
So I always was fascinated
with education as a lever.
Like, you could have an
innovation in a particular domain,
but if you can allow hundreds
of thousands or millions
or billions of humans to
up-level their potential,
that could create innovation and progress
in thousands of domains
and in millions of different areas.
And so you fast forward to
when I was tutoring my cousins
and I started making tools
for them, software for them,
started making videos for them,
I started to realize, you know,
the things that I'm doing for my cousins,
in theory, they could scale to the world.
It wouldn't be simple, but they could,
they could scale to the world with help,
well, in partnership
with many other folks.
And so that was the first
time I said maybe this could,
maybe Khan Academy could be an institution
for the world that does that.
And you know, when I was operating
out of the same walk-in
closet than I am right now,
because of COVID, it
was a little delusional
for a guy in a walk in
closet to say what if we,
I guess at the time it was I,
what if I could create an institution
that could one day educate billions,
but you know, sometimes you
have to make a little bit
of a delusional bet,
but then put one foot
in front of the other
and make progress and
keep chipping away at it.
And before you know it,
as long as you are willing
to keep failing forward,
before you know, it,
you're reaching 10 people,
100 people, 1,000, 10,000,
100,000, million, 10 million.
And you know today,
Khan Academy has over 100
million registered users
and we're nowhere near done.
There's billions of students
for generations to come,
who could benefit from Khan
Academy and Khan Academy is
doing a lot of good work.
And it's much more than me now,
but there's a lot more that we can do
to support all these folks.
But, you know, big picture,
that's where the thinking came from
for what Khan Academy should be.
So from, from Facebook,
wow, I'm getting a lot
of questions from Khans,
my extended family, maybe. (laughs)
Zarina Khan.
"Hi, Sal, interesting books this late,
(stammers) these days,
looking for a recommendation."
So the book that I am reading right now,
and I don't recommend it for
maybe anyone under the age of 18 or 21,
this was recommended by a friend of mine,
it's named "Shantaram".
And I'm not giving the book away.
It's about a, an Australian
who escapes from prison
and then kind of is in exile
to some degree in India
and how he starts working with the,
the underworld in Bombay.
And it's an interesting
book, fascinating book.
It's both, there's a lot of action,
but there's a lot of philosophy as well,
but it's also quite dark and violent.
I tend to be a fan personally,
of like the Disney Pixar school of movies.
So it's, for me, it's a little grittier
than what I normally,
what I normally look at.
I will tell you one thing
that I'm really enjoying
watching these days,
which is closer to the Disney
Pixar flavor of entertainment.
I just finished watching
the "Avatar: The Last Airbender"
series with my children.
I think it's on Netflix.
And then we just,
I think we have to pay
money for this next one,
but now we're watching the sequel,
which is "The Legend of Korra".
And I am somewhat addicted to these.
I highly highly recommend those.
I like 'em 'cause you know,
they're just good character development.
They have, they actually have
some interesting philosophy in them.
And yeah, they're just
really, really good stories.
Other things that I've been
reading lately, you know,
my close friends will tell you,
I'm reading this and I guess you could say
with a nonreligious lens,
but really for more of
a philosophical lens,
you know, I've been reading
a lot of Marcus Aurelius,
"Meditation's", very related to that.
You know, things like
"Dhammapada" from Buddha,
there's a lot of overlap between them,
the "Bhagavad Gita" and "Upanishads".
I've been going into
kind of a exploration of,
I would say philosophy,
especially Eastern philosophies,
but stoicism, you know,
which is obviously,
a Greek and Roman philosophical system
is actually quite, quite close
to I would say the underlying philosophy
of the "Vedas" or Buddha.
So those have been other areas
that I've been spending
a lot of time reading.
And obviously that's related,
I've talked before, I've
been meditating a lot.
And I think there's a lot of
interesting insights about,
you know, who we are, especially when you,
when you start to try to
still your mind a little bit.
Let's see, from YouTube, Bauman Dang says,
"I'm in middle school.
How can I use Khan Academy
for distance learning?"
Well, Bauman, we're
there for you. (laughs)
There's a couple of ways.
There's many ways you can do it.
I mean, easily in math, I
would say go to Khan Academy.
I don't know what grade you're in.
Let's you're in seventh grade
or eighth grade or sixth grade,
go to Khan Academy.
I would start at the "Get
Ready For Grade Level" course.
So let's say you're going
to enter seventh grade.
I would start with the "Get
Ready For Seventh Grade" course
on Khan Academy.
I would take the course challenge.
If on that course challenge,
you got an 80 or 90%,
that means you're ready for seventh grade.
And then I would just
go into seventh grade.
If you've always been a
little bit precocious in math,
then you could even take the
seventh grade course challenge
and get credit for what you already know.
And then start working working on that
at your own time and pace.
If you've got less than a 70%
on the "Get Ready For Grade
Level" course, not a big deal.
Just keep working on that
so you have really strong foundations
and then work on the grade level course.
My suggested implementation for you,
if you have no other supports,
hopefully, you know, your parents
or teachers can support you as well,
but if you're able to put in
even 30 minutes a day, I think,
I think as a middle schooler, you know,
Monday through Friday, if
you're able, able to go 40,
45 minutes a day into Khan Academy,
maybe split it up into two
sessions of 20 minutes each,
you will find after about a month or two
that you're making really,
really good progress.
And the important thing is
when you do those 20 minutes,
try to focus on the problem solving.
The videos are there for support.
If you have trouble with something,
you can look at hints, see how a solution,
the solution to whatever
you might've missed,
but keep reflecting on
what you're working on.
Use the videos to get yourself
introduced to new concepts
or clarify concepts that you
having trouble understanding,
but keep working on the exercises.
I suspect that if you keep doing that
even over a few months,
you're going to notice
a very big difference
in your confidence in mathematics
and how far you've been accelerated.
And if you just keep doing that,
I think regardless of where you start,
within a year you'll be ahead
of where you need to be.
So that's in math and you know,
you're middle school student,
we have a lot of high school science.
I do think some of the high school science
could be consumable by you, I
would say, especially biology.
So that's something to explore,
some of the biology content.
I think some of the early
chemistry content on Khan Academy,
you could also start looking at.
The physics, you need
a little bit more math,
if you're precocious and math
and you know a little bit of,
a little bit of algebra and trig,
then you really need to know quadratics
and the basics of trigonometry in order
to engage in our physics course.
But I would say the chemistry
and biology, for sure.
And then on the humanities
side, that's where,
we don't have as much for you
as a middle school student.
We do have some beta English
and language arts things
that you can do to practice
reading comprehension.
What I do recommend actually,
now that I think about it is, you could,
and I'm not saying, I'm not
trying to be a tiger cousin
telling you take an SAT when
you're in middle school,
although there are some programs
that if you take the SAT in middle school,
you can get into some summer camps,
and scholarships and whatever else.
But I would say our SAT practice,
which covers reading,
writing, and mathematics,
it actually is really good to
start as a middle schooler.
Once again, not because
you need to take the SAT
when you're in seventh or eighth grade,
but because some of those concepts,
the easier questions on the SAT
are actually roughly at
a middle school level.
And so if you get practice with that,
it'll stretch you a little bit
into kind of more advanced middle school
and high school topics.
And then you'll have
really good development,
at least on the baseline
reading comprehension, grammar,
and then on the math as well.
You can do the SAT work
or you could do the Khan Academy work.
I think if you did that during COVID,
you'll be doing all right.
And then I would supplement that.
Or on top of that, I would make sure
to be doing some regular
reading every day,
do some reading for fun,
read some newspapers, magazines,
and do some regular writing.
Whether it's journaling,
try to force yourself,
write a weekly blog post and email it
to all your family so they give feedback.
You know, just things that you care about,
just get in the habit of writing about it.
I think if you do that handful of things,
you're going to be in good shape
as we go through this
very difficult period.
So from YouTube, A space Z says,
"Sal, how are you coping with quarantine?"
Thanks for asking, A Z.
So, you know, if I'm honest,
I almost feel guilty.
I feel very blessed.
Quarantine has been kind to me.
My children's school
has done a wonderful job
of keeping them with kind
of distance learning,
keeping up with them.
My wife has been incredibly supportive.
Many of y'all know she's
a physician, but you know,
she's able to work three days a week.
So two days she's able to help, you know,
I'm here in the house with the kids,
but obviously I'm kind of, you know,
super into my work a lot of that time.
So it really helps that my
wife is here two days a week.
And then my mother-in-law lives with us.
And you know, I know that
the mother-in-law stereotype
can go in different directions,
but I have a very, very,
very good mother-in-law
and she definitely is a
great person to have around
and is really great with the kids
and helps support our entire family.
And so I feel very
fortunate on that level.
I think on the Khan
Academy, on my work level,
you know, there's some puts and takes,
I know it's been hard on many
people in the organization,
especially with childcare issues.
Our organization itself
has done a good job.
We always had a lot of
distributed employees.
So this was kind of natural for us
to do a lot of our work in
a distributed or remote way.
Khan Academy has had a
very big role to play
in this COVID world.
So, you know, we
definitely have a lot to do
and I in some ways feel lucky
that there's a role for us
to play, to help people,
to help folks keep learning
during social distancing.
Many of y'all know, I'm
not a big fan of planes.
I like travel once I get to
the place that I'm getting to.
I like looking at new places
and exploring new places
and meeting new folks. But
I really don't like planes,
if I'm very honest with
you, I just don't like them
for many, many, many reasons.
And so I do consider it a
little bit of a blessing
that I haven't had to get on
a plane in many, many months.
In fact, I consider
that a massive blessing.
(laughs) And yeah, so overall, you know,
considering what's going on in the world,
I consider myself a very
lucky, but you know,
some of this is hitting
very close to home.
One of our good friends, her
father in Maryland passed
due to COVID.
So, you know, it's not
like this is, you know,
this is a real thing that's
happening to folks all around,
but, but relatively speaking,
I'm doing just fine, but thanks.
Thanks for asking.
So, let's see, there is
from YouTube, Prisha B says,
"What should I say to a person
who thinks that being knowledgeable
is just getting good grades?"
Well,
no matter what you are asking me about,
one thing, you know, you learn over time,
is it's hard to change someone.
So, there might not be anything
that you could tell them
that would overnight make them change
how they perceive the world.
Getting good grades is
helpful, but really, you know,
getting good grades is a mechanism,
or a means, or a incentive mechanism,
hopefully to get knowledge.
And I think what you're implying
is there are some very
knowledgeable people who,
who might not have the best grades
or didn't have the best grades.
And there are some people
who had very good grades,
who might not be, you know,
wise to the world, so to speak
is what I think you're going at.
And these things don't necessarily,
they might be correlated, but they're not,
they're not as a strong correlation
as maybe your friend my might imply.
So I think,
if you could show them the
video of what I'm about to say,
which is, you know, I've
always optimized my life.
I actually, I got mostly A's,
but I always optimized for the learning.
I was always more about,
hey, this is interesting,
let me learn it, I'm curious about it,
and my grades will be what they are.
And, I got my share of
A minuses and, you know,
I got a B here and there, (laughs)
and it was usually I got
the A minuses or the B's
because I wasn't trying
to optimize for the grade,
I was trying to optimize
for the knowledge,
which usually correlated with the grade.
But I think that made school
way more interesting for me
and it gave me a really strong foundation,
I think, of curiosity and being able
to connect things in the world.
And I also think, you know,
even when you think about
things like college admissions,
there's sometimes a
notion that if I get one B
or even one A minus,
I'm out of the running,
and I know college admissions
and things like that,
they're super competitive,
or even certain jobs,
your GPA has to be a certain threshold
for you to look at it,
so grades matter in that.
But I found that if
your grades are decent,
or quite good but maybe
not absolutely perfect,
but you are able to show
real capability and curiosity
and knowledge in other
areas that is really,
you know, shines in certain ways,
stands out in certain ways,
that you'll be at least as successful
as the absolute perfect grades.
So, you know, I'm not anti-grades.
You should definitely do what you can,
people do look at those things,
but maybe they're necessary,
but they're not sufficient I would say
if you really want to
appreciate the beauty
and the mystery of the world.
So let's see.
And I'll say frankly, a lot
of the knowledge that I have,
I've gotten after I
left the school system.
So, I'm not being graded anymore.
So if you want to stay knowledgeable,
you have to keep wanting to learn,
even when no one's grading you.
All right, so let's see, other questions.
From Facebook, Cecilia
Loong says, "Hi, Sal.
Would love to hear more
about your meditation.
What you do, where does your thought go,
how long, how did you find it
before and after, et cetera?"
Well, thanks for the questions
Cecilia and, you know,
I like to be careful
on, on this live stream.
I don't want to turn into, you
know, someone on a soap box,
you know, just telling
people about my meditation,
et cetera, et cetera.
But you know, what actually got me in,
I was always kind of
intrigued by meditation.
I've always heard about it.
When I was younger I tried it
and it just didn't make sense to me.
I'd be like, okay, I sit quietly
and my brain's like,
"Why are you doing this?
This is a waste of time."
And your thoughts start wandering.
So it never really made
a lot of sense to me.
And then, y'all just heard
that I don't like planes.
And if I'm very open with you,
it was planes, (stammers)
there a little bit of the fear of flying.
I did always come to terms with death
before getting on a plane.
So I've come to terms with
death many times, I think.
But more than that actually,
it was actually the claustrophobia for me.
And I actually didn't even
know what claustrophobia was.
(stammers) I knew what it was.
I knew people had fear of small places,
but I never understood what a phobia was
until I started to experience it myself.
People say it often hits you
in your late 30s or early 40s.
Oftentimes if you're a parent, you know,
whatever claustrophobia or anxiety
or whatever you might call it, you know,
we could theorize why maybe as a parent
you're always anxious as
to what might go wrong
with your children,
(laughs) and then that,
that kind of hardwires those circuits.
But for whatever reason,
about five, six years ago,
I never liked planes.
But about five, six years ago,
the claustrophobia got quite bad,
where I would get on a plane
and all I could think about is, wow
I have to sit in this plane
for the next five hours,
It's like this capsule,
I can't get off of it,
and then your brain just starts doing
these very irrational things.
You know, a part of your
brain is saying, hey, brain,
you're being irrational,
chill out, just, you know,
watch a movie and read
a book and take a nap
and you're gonna be in New
York before you know it,
but it's a very unpleasant
feeling for anyone who has gone
through that.
It's arguably one of the
worst feelings you can have.
And, I was talking about this
with a board member of mine
who has to travel frankly, way
more than I have to travel.
And he says, "Well, you know,
I actually have the same issue
and meditation really helped."
And I was like, okay, well, I'll try it.
(stammers) I didn't want to
resort to having to do any,
you know, medication or anything like that
if I didn't have to.
So I'm like, let me try meditation.
And so, on his recommendation,
I downloaded the Headspace app
and I started doing that
somewhat religiously.
I did 10 minutes a day
for two, three months
and I kind of started
getting into that pattern.
And then I started to actually
see the benefits of it,
that it really got your mind stilled
instead of allowing your
mind to kind of race
in a bunch of different directions,
you do, as you get more and more practice,
get to a spot, not all the
time, my mind still wanders,
but more often or more
common than not now,
I'm able to get my mind into a place
where it's kind of still,
and there's kind of not this thought.
And when you do that regularly,
you're less likely to get worked up.
You're less likely to get anxious.
Even now, if I'm at work or in other areas
and a debate is happening
that normally I would
get very worked up about,
now I'm much more zen about it.
I'm like look, Sal, you
know, do what you need to do,
but don't get too worked up.
These thoughts aren't you.
You aren't defined by whether you win
or lose this debate, et cetera.
So anyway, that's how
I got into meditation.
I would say after a few
months, I kind of just,
I guess you could say
graduated from the app.
And, and now I do,
I try to do at least 30 minutes a day.
And you know, I just sit quietly,
upright posture and,
I do kind of a, a body scan, so to speak,
just become aware of my surroundings.
But then I try to just still my mind
and just kind of sit in that moment.
And my mind definitely
does still gravitate to,
oh, you got to do this for work,
oh, you forgot to take out the trash,
oh, why did that person say
that to you the other day,
did they do they mean
what you think they said.
So your brain,
your brain definitely wanders.
But then the other key is laugh it off.
A lot of people take meditation
a little bit too seriously.
And then they become stressed out.
Like, you know, you start meditating
and there's like a lawnmower outside.
You're like, "Oh, a lawnmower.
I can't say on the lawnmower!"
And then obviously that
defeats the purpose.
What you really should do is
like, "Oh, that's interesting.
There's a lawnmower.
A lawnmower as part of
this reality, how nice."
So, the more that you smile
externally and internally,
while you meditate in the
morning that you're accepting
of whatever sensations,
whatever thoughts come about,
you don't try to fight 'em,
it's like, "Oh, look at that thought.
That's not the most positive thought,
but it's one of the thoughts.
So here, thought, why don't
you move on a little bit?"
(laughs) I think that
the healthier it can be.
So, from Facebook, Malini Kishore asks,
"How can I, as a parent,
instill or encourage curiosity
in my eight and 10 year olds?
Thanks.
And please expand to older ages too."
So, you know, it's interesting.
'Cause I actually think
all kids have curiosity
pre-installed, so to speak.
(laughs) So I don't think you
have to instill them with it,
it's already there.
I think what you need to
do is give space for it
and not squeeze it out.
And you know, most kids, the
way you give space for it
is when they want to take an
old toilet paper roll or a box
and they want to make
something, as a parent,
and I have to remind this
to myself all the time.
Half the time me or my wife,
we're like, oh, we're busy,
we have to go to this thing,
or you're late for this practice,
or I'm busy, don't bother me,
why are you making a mess over there.
You know, these are natural parent things
to do every now and then.
And I have to admit I'm not great at this.
I often fall into what I just described.
I'm like, wait, wait,
this is really cool what
my daughter wants to do.
She wants to cut up that thing
that I was about to throw
away and make this thing.
Maybe I should sit down with her
and work with her a little bit.
Okay, maybe they'll make
a little bit of a mess
if they try to take those paints
and do this with it on the kitchen counter
and this and that, but maybe
a little bit of that's okay.
(stammers) I don't practice
what I preach all the time,
just to be very clear.
I'm even thinking about some times
in my own head over the last week
where I probably shut
down my kids' creativity
by telling them, "Hey, Hey, no
don't make a mess over there.
Wait, wait, we just clean the room"
or, "Wait, wait, why do you want to,
why are you digging in the trash?
Why are you taking that box
out? I just flattened it."
(laughs) Or whatever else.
So I think giving that
space for them is key.
I think giving, sitting
down with them on the ground
and doing it with them, I
actually think there's a lot
about modeling creativity for them.
A lot of adults kind of
think they're past the age
where they should sit down and draw,
they should sit down and write a poem,
or sing a song, or compose a song.
So that's another area.
I think a lot of our,
what in theory our creative pursuits,
like playing a musical instrument,
or visual arts, in our
goal oriented world,
oftentimes become less
creative where you just,
you know, in the musical instrument,
"Okay, now play a harder piece.
Okay, now play a harder piece.
Learn this technique,
learn that technique."
Well, really the musical instruments
are about creative expression.
And so, you know, I think the more
that we can emphasize,
say young piano learners,
to also compose their own pieces,
which you don't see in piano class.
My son has a great piano teacher
and he's doing a great job, but you know,
I definitely encouraged my
son, "Compose your own pieces."
This is about expression.
This is not just about being able
to play a more difficult
piece a little bit faster
and with a little bit more
technical sophistication.
That's useful, too.
That's going to build
your underlying skills,
but there's a whole
creative aspect to this.
I would say, even in math,
a lot of what you might learn,
these are the techniques,
these are the tools,
but math is also a creative field.
And so, you know, always have some fun,
enriching problems to do.
Me and my kids, we've been
doing some number theory,
which obviously isn't in
the Common Core standards
or anything,
but they're just these
interesting logic puzzles
and number theory puzzles
that you have to be,
you have to kind of
have a creative mindset
to try to think of a solution
or try to think of a proof.
So yeah, I would say model it with them,
participate with them, and,
get out of their way a lot of times.
And I would also say
don't over-schedule them.
Creativity is oftentimes
a byproduct of boredom.
So a little bit of boredom is good.
And over time, any human being
who is sufficiently bored
will figure out something to do,
and that usually is a creative activity.
So, this is, let's see,
for other questions.
From Facebook, Julie Ramos Jones.
"I have a junior in high school
who will be starting
distance learning in August.
What can I do to help her succeed,
accomplishing her graduation requirements
through distance learning?"
So, Julie, I don't know all of your,
all of your daughter's circumstances.
So I think on the learning side,
a lot of the advice that I gave
to the middle school student
a couple of minutes ago,
I think would apply to your daughter.
You know, math, we've got her
back, whatever level she's at,
whether she's at trigonometry,
pre-calculus, calculus,
stats, work on Khan Academy.
I would say two 30 minute sessions a day
would be incredible.
Hopefully she has support from her school
or her peers or from you if
she gets stuck on anything.
Actually, there's this other effort
that I've talked about here before
called schoolhouse.world,
which is a, not a Khan Academy effort,
it's a separate effort,
maybe one day it becomes
a Khan Academy effort,
but it's to pair students
who need help with a subject,
especially in math,
we're starting in math,
but eventually might go to other subjects
and volunteer tutors running
group tutoring sessions.
So that's another layer of support
that we might be able to also provide,
or that the side project
might be able to provide,
schoolhouse.world.
So between Khan Academy,
she should be able to get
enough practice in math
and then get these other supports.
And then in science, we
also have got her back.
We have high school and AP
level physics, chemistry,
biology, econ, also in the humanities,
American history and
government and politics.
I'd say all of that content is perfect
for the age that your daughter's at.
If the question is
around credit, you know,
this is gonna be really
interesting this year,
where colleges are going to
have a lot less information.
A lot of schools have gone to pass/fail,
or they're just passing
everyone because of,
you know, inequity to access
of devices and things.
And so I think the successful students
are going to have to come
up with alternate ways
of showing colleges that they've made it
or that they've not made it, that they've,
they've met their requirements
and that they know the material.
Meeting the requirements, most,
if you think about like the
state university systems,
most state university systems
have an alternative way
to prove your competencies.
Most private schools,
at the end of the day,
tend to be less rigid about,
most private colleges,
tend to be less rigid
about their requirements.
More that they want to see
the, are you college ready?
Are you a caring person who
wants to help the world?
What are your capabilities
in different subject areas?
And there's a lot of
ways you can show that.
You can do that with SAT.
Maybe you can even show your mastery.
We had Jim Nondorf from
the University of Chicago
on this live stream a
couple of months ago.
And you know, Jim and I have
been talking about, well,
he would love to see kids submit
their Khan Academy mastery
because not only would that,
let's say your daughter able
is able to get 90% mastery
on calculus on Khan Academy,
if she wanted to apply
to University Chicago,
and she submitted that,
from Jim's point of view,
not only that be a pretty good indication
that she knows her calculus,
but it also is an indication
that she's a self-learner,
she has a lot of agency.
You know, even in a tough time like COVID
when a lot of things are hit and miss,
she's able to drive her
own learning forward,
which I think would look good.
I also think people
don't use video enough.
A video is a great way
to advocate for yourself.
One thing that I do, and
the few times, you know,
every now and then whether it's a student
that I've worked with or
whatever wants a recommendation,
I actually make
recommendation videos for them
because it becomes, you can't fake that.
(laughs) It's like, you know,
it's not like someone else
wrote it and just signed it.
And I would say you can
advocate yourself in that
for yourself in that same way.
If you can create video artifacts,
that show things that you've created,
that show you explaining concepts,
then that only adds to your,
to your portfolio to show
that not only do you know the material,
not only have you done
cool, creative things,
but you also know how to
communicate your work.
And I think that is also another way
to self-advocate frankly,
at any age, at any age.
So anyway, those are my, my ideas.
I am trying to talk to state leaders,
college folks for what
if Khan Academy itself,
mastery on Khan Academy could count
towards the state
requirements for graduation
or towards the state
university requirements.
Maybe there's a way that
a teacher can validate
that it's the student's
work, proctor them some way.
Maybe you could take a course
challenge on Khan Academy
and talk out loud on audio
while you're doing it
and submit the audio too.
So people like, "Look,
I clearly did this work.
I'm thinking out loud
doing every problem."
That's hard to fake.
So stuff like that,
but it's going to be an
interesting challenge,
especially if COVID lasts,
and it looks like it very well could last
for another year or even longer.
So, we're all out of time.
This is these, these always go,
these always go super fast.
So I'll answer one last
question from Facebook.
Selma Malek says, "My eight year old
is interested in coding,
but I don't want to encourage
too much screen time.
He likes Scratch.
What else should he do?
How old are your kids?"
Well, my kids are 11, nine and 5 1/2,
and they are also into coding.
They've used scratch.
They've used Tinker.
They've used the Khan Academy coding.
Screen time is an interesting debate.
I think if a child is doing
really creative things
like writing on a screen,
like writing a paper
or a blog post, or if
they're editing video,
or if they are coding,
that is a good use of screen time.
And so for child that is eager to code,
I would say, yes,
definitely let them code.
But the more important thing is make sure
that they're also getting
other healthy things
in their life, making sure
that they're spending
a good amount of time
getting their vitamin D out
in the sun, running around,
getting breathless as much as possible
in this COVID-19 socially distanced world;
they're able to interact
with other people,
have social connections,
that they have just
free time to themselves;
that there's time with the family,
that they're eating right, sleeping right.
If they're doing all of
that stuff, coding is great.
And it's a great outlet creativity.
You know, I remember I didn't,
(stammers) I didn't
start coding until later.
But it was an incredible
outlet for creativity for me.
And sometimes when I was
really into creating a new game
or a new app, I would
spend 12 hours straight.
And I think almost anyone
who's really immersed
in a creative field will tell you
they spend 12 hours
straight at least sometimes
when they're really in the zone.
And there's nothing wrong with that.
In fact, I think that's good,
once again, as long as
they're eating right,
they're getting their exercise,
they're running outside,
they're not only on a screen all day,
then I think, you know,
the bad screen time
is where you're kind of just vegged out,
watching something and you're just kinda,
you know, whatever.
That's probably the stuff that,
watching people unpackage
toys or something,
(laughs) that can be or worse,
that could be a little less productive.
But anyway, thanks everyone.
These are really good questions.
I'll try to get to them on the next AMA.
Just a reminder to everyone
who was expecting to
see Anthony Fauci today,
they had to reschedule to Friday.
So, still very excited
about that conversation.
We're going to be talking
about obviously COVID
and school closures related to COVID.
So very, very excited
about that conversation.
So thanks everyone for joining.
I really enjoy these "Ask Me Anythings"
and look forward to
seeing you all on Friday.
(digital chiming)